ya estamos a dos meses de protestas es
muchísimo tomando en cuenta además que
es un contexto de inflación bastante
fuerte en Europa y en Francia Entonces
esta gente no puede estar estar
Eternamente en las calles pero lo que no
se puede esconder es que a pesar de esta
bajada de movilización que quizás
también es una una un cambio también del
mundo de protestación lo que podemos
decir es que la frustración general es
muy fuerte mucho más fuerte que antes y
que la oposición a este proyecto sigue
manteniendo a un nivel muy alto y
floriana ahora hablaremos no de la
frustración social Pero antes abordemos
el hecho de que mañana el consejo
constitucional decidirá si este texto
está amparado por la Constitución qué
puntos de la ley podrían ser declarados
inconstitucionales
hay dos solicitudes que fueron
presentadas durante el consejo de el
consejo constitucional el primero es por
los diputados de de izquierda que y de
extrema derecha que contesta los
posibles o que llamamos nosotros los
vehículos legislativos este tratan de
artículos que no tendrían nada que ver
con el propósito de un proyecto de ley
que es un proyecto de ley
presupuestarial y el segundo es uno de
una solicitud que viene de los senadores
de izquierda que crítica el límite del
debate impuesto por el gobierno con el
uso de cuarenta y nueve punto tres es un
artículo que ya se ha hablado y que yo
mismo había mencionado aquí en Francia
24 el 442 y el 38 es la acumulación de
todos estos artículos que hubieran
limitado el debate dentro del parlamento
y que entonces perjudicarían la
legitimidad de este texto y en función
de lo que se decida mañana de decida el
consejo constitucional que escenarios se
abren para el movimiento contra la
reforma
Bueno para mí hay tres escenarios el
primero es un escenario que yo llamo ni
fuera de la Constitución ni fuera de las
manos del pueblo es decir el consejo va
a censurar parte de los artículos con
los vehículos legislativos que estaba
explicando dentro de estos el tipo de
contrato para las personas de más de 60
años y ahí lo más importante sería
salvado por el gobierno porque la edad
para jubilarse sería mantenida a los 64
años y no fuera de las manos del pueblo
porque el consejo constitucional también
puede validar la iniciativa de la
compartida es una iniciativa que está
permitida después de un cambio de dentro
de la constitución en 2009 que permite
con la solicitud de unos diputados de
impulsar un referéndum a nivel nacional
y aquí es muy importante porque si se
logra esta este
ahí se votaría la cancelación de la ley
y será claramente un voto A favor o en
contra del gobierno con un riesgo
entonces de caída del ejecutivo actual
el escenario dos para mí está censura
integral pero aquí estamos sobre un
riesgo que es muy importante sería una
humillación para el gobierno actual
porque solamente se hizo 20 veces dentro
de toda la historia de la quinta
República y las consecuencias ahora no
se pueden medir porque según yo la
renuncia de la ministra sería definitiva
no habrá otra opción sobre todo porque
ya se posicionó como la la experta
quizás de la negociación y vimos el
resultado Tendremos una alianza de
izquierda que va a bloquear todo va a
imponer este bloqueo una derecha que
podría intentar una alianza con el
macroismo pero es un partido que es muy
debilitado y muy muy pequeño en
comparación al macroismo Entonces sería
decir que el patronismo tendrá que hacer
muchos sacrificios para tener esta
Alianza y tener la mayoría en el
parlamento y la extrema derecha que va a
seguir bloqueando igual y el tercer
escenario no es la validación del texto
en su completitud con un riesgo alto de
un divorcio de una parte del pueblo con
la con la contra las instituciones de la
quinta República eso vamos a ver después
con el nivel de movilización existe la
fuerte o no